we all do things that we know we really
shouldn't like you want some water
sure
or apologizing all the time
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry
oh sorry yeah actually I'm not sorry
about this
looking up pictures of beautiful people
for hours just so you can validate how
shitty you want to feel about yourself
fuck trick being passive-aggressive
so there is an in-and-out and a Denny's
which one do you want to go to Denny's
sounds good
are you sure are you sure yeah that's
what you really want getting pissed off
at your boyfriend when he's being an
asshole
in your dreams that son of a bitch and
talking shit
Cindy keeps saying she's gonna pay me
back for the last three meals that are
spotted her but then never pays me back
oh my god so rude I can't believe her I
know right wait she's calling me now
hold on
hey thin Dee oh my god Becca's being
such a bitch I owe her some money for a
few meals and I told her I'd freakin pay
her back on Friday when I got my
paycheck and she's like hounding me and
demanding 20% interest now oh my god
that is totally not what she said to me
oh what a fucker I am still on the line
you bitches the list goes on
right like spending money that you don't
have hanging on to toxic relationships
and friendships having your entire life
revolve around your significant other
well what do you do that you know you
really shouldn't and does that ever stop
you or do you just keep doing it I will
see you on Friday